un été 2010 8 exceptionnel dans les
yvelines le département a connu sa
deuxième période estivale la plus chaude
depuis 1900 derrière la canicule de 2003
des températures caniculaires venus du
nord du maghreb du sud de l'espagne qui
ont persisté jusqu'au 8 août
attrape le maximum début août on a eu du
35 7 degrés donc oui si la station de
trappes
on a eu plus de 13 jours 2
où les températures maximales ont
dépassé les 30 degrés pour comparaison
en moyenne on est plutôt sur sept à huit
jours
sur l'été alors je parle d'été de juin
juillet et août un compris les trois et
trois mois on a des températures
supérieures à 30 degrés donc là on était
largement au dessus
pour cet automne l'été caniculaire
pourrait se transformer en été indien
les bonnes et les pubs ne devrait pas
être de sortie avant la mi-octobre sur
les premiers indicateurs pour le moment
quand on regarde les prévisions
saisonnières donc pour septembre octobre
et novembre
on s'acheminerait vers un automne un peu
plus doux que la normale à l'automne
approche mais avec tout doucement
puisque la dent les début septembre et
va être presque estivales dans les jours
qui viennent
l'été devrait effectivement joué les
prolongations dans le département météo
france prévoit pour la fin de la semaine
des températures aussi entre 23 et 25
degrés accompagné de soleil 3 4 degrés
au dessus des normales de saison